Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在切入今天的节目之前，我想先和大家分享一件正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于你的被动收入，而不是把时间无休止地出卖给金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“冲刺持续性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Trent.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接参加挑战赛，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一小时一对一指导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。快去访问我的 Linktree 链接（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正打算成为一名心理学家，那就让这期节目成为你的指南。节目，主讲人是玛丽安·特伦特博士。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for listening. So when we are working in mental health there can feel like a lot of different issues that we need to be aware of and it can feel like a very quick-paced, quick-moving beast really to get our heads around and how best to understand the broad variety of people that we work with and their unique needs that might well be different to our needs personally and professionally and one of the recent very important debates and themes that have been raised in the media but also in mental health has been that of gender and diversity and I'm delighted to be able to welcome my guest today so that we can all think about how to understand more about these important issues and how we might be able to make changes in the way that we do things in our personal and professional practice
你好，欢迎收听“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名认证临床心理学家。非常感谢你的收听。当我们从事心理健康工作时，会感觉到有许多不同的议题需要我们去关注；要理解我们所服务的、背景各异的广大群体以及他们独一无二的需求，这在现实中感觉像是一个节奏极快、不断变化的庞然大物。他们的需求可能与我们在个人和职业上的需求截然不同。近期在媒体以及心理健康领域被提出并引发热议的一个非常重要的论题和主题，就是性别与多元化。我非常高兴能邀请到今天的嘉宾，以便我们大家共同思考：如何更多地了解这些重要议题，以及我们如何在个人和职业实践中改变做事的方式，
to better be inclusive and to yeah help other people know how open to conversations we are in this area and how we strive to help people feel understood validated and heard and seen please do stick around to the end because you will be able to learn about an exclusive competition that I'm running to win two very exciting prizes. But you'll need to take action quick because the entry will close a week today. It will close at midnight on Monday, the 2nd of January 2023. So dive in, listen to this episode to find out how you can enter the competition which is linked to the content of today's podcast. So with no further ado let me shush and introduce you to our wonderful guest for today. Hope you find it so useful. I'll see you on the other side with more information about that competition. Hi, welcome along to today's episode of the
从而更好地做到包容，并且……是的，帮助其他人知道我们在这个领域对对话是多么开放，以及我们如何努力让人们感受到被理解、被认可、被倾听和被看见。请务必收听到最后，因为你将了解到我正在举办的一个独家比赛，内含两个非常令人兴奋的奖品。但你需要迅速行动，因为参赛通道将于今天起一周后关闭。它将于 2023 年 1 月 2 日星期一午夜截止。所以快来行动吧，收听本期节目，了解如何参加与今天播客内容相关的比赛。废话不多说，让我闭嘴，把我们今天精彩的嘉宾介绍给大家。希望你会觉得非常有用。稍后我会在节目结束时带来更多关于该比赛的信息。你好，欢迎收听本期
Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am thrilled to be introducing you to G. Sabini Roberts. Hi, G. Hi. So there's a number of reasons I wanted to talk to you in today's episode, because you're just a really interesting character to get to know. So we met on socials and I've been following your work for a while and you're really inspiring for a number of reasons. By trade, you're a brand specialist of doing branding and logos and things like that is that right? That is right yeah the original business 11 years old now yeah it's graphic design with a very definite brand specialism yeah. Yeah but you definitely have a more modern twist on the way you work and the topics that you talk about and that's really what I want to talk with you and to our audience about today. So originally I wanted to talk to you for a little bit of help really, a little bit of guidance
《有志心理学家播客》。我非常高兴向大家介绍 G·萨比尼·罗伯茨（G. Sabini Roberts）。你好，G。你好。我今天想跟你聊聊有很多原因，因为你是一个非常有趣、很值得去了解的人物。我们在社交媒体上认识的，我关注你的作品已经有一段时间了，由于很多原因，你真的非常鼓舞人心。按行当来说，你是一位品牌专家，专门做品牌设计、标志设计之类的，对吗？是的，没错。最初的业务现在已经 11 年了，对，是带有非常明确品牌专科方向的平面设计，对的。是的，但你工作的方式以及你谈论的话题显然具有更现代的风格，这正是我今天想和你以及我们的听众探讨的。所以最初我想找你，其实是想寻求一点帮助和指导，
for how we can be really inclusive in modern mental health services, for thinking about diversity and gender and all stuff along those lines. what's your best advice for how we can do things better in modern mental health services gee oh what a huge question I think based on on the conversation you and I have already had what we really want to talk about is is confidence and comfort in being able to talk about these things. So just in terms of background, I'm queer, I'm non-binary, trans, I use people who are LGBTQ, we end up inadvertently delivering awareness, training, information, being the go-to voice because we're the only gay that somebody knows, for example. We all do that anyway. That's something we do for free every day of the week. However, a few years ago, we started offering that, myself and a couple of partners started offering that on a professional basis as well.
探讨我们如何在现代心理健康服务中真正做到包容，思考多元化、性别以及所有相关的话题。对于我们如何在现代心理健康服务中把事情做得更好，你有什么最好的建议吗，G？哦，这真是个巨大的问题！我想，基于你和我之前已经进行的交流，我们真正想谈论的是在能够谈论这些事情时的自信和舒适感。所以就背景而言，我是酷儿，我是非二元性别者，我是跨性别者，我们这些属于 LGBTQ 的人，往往会在无意中承担起普及意识、培训、提供信息的责任，成为首选的代言人，因为我们是某人认识的唯一的同性恋，举个例子。我们所有人无论如何都在做这件事。这是我们一周七天、每天都在免费做的事情。然而，几年前我和几个合伙人开始以专业的形式也提供这种服务。
So I have that slant to things too, but I'm very much an LGBTQ specialist within that. So really, I think the biggest question for most people seems to be example how do I speak with them refer to their past talk to them in a way that enables them to access whatever it is we're trying to access in a way that includes them and doesn't put up barriers is that right is that is that where do you think that kind of thing is what will be useful for people here absolutely yes please Okay so the first aspect of this is to recognise that when it comes to gender identity particularly gender identity is is an identity it's how you feel in your head your gender is between your ears not between your legs is a brilliant quote
所以我在这方面也有这样的背景，但在其中我非常明确地是一个 LGBTQ 专家。所以真的，对大多数人来说最大的问题似乎是：例如，我该如何与他们交谈、指称他们的过去、以一种能够让他们获取我们试图获取的任何资源的方式与他们对话，这种方式要能包容他们而不会设立障碍？是这样吗？你认为大家在这里会觉得有用的是这类事情吗？完全是的，求之不得。好的，那么这方面的第一个方面是要认识到，当谈到性别认同，特别是性别认同，它是一种认同，它是你在脑海中的感受。你的性别在你的双耳之间，而不在你的双腿之间，这是一个绝妙的名言。
that's a Charles Bono magical quote but it's true so when we're talking from a psychological point of view it is very much it's an identity that is owned and it does not necessarily correlate in any way shape or form with somebody's physiology biology anatomy hormones chromosomes all of the things that go into making a biological sex and it's important to acknowledge that because somebody may walk into a room and you look at them and you clock them as a particular gender and you do not know that that's the case until you've actually asked them if that's how they identify and this is why it's sometimes really easy to inadvertently put our foot in it because we make assumptions and that's the first thing is to recognize that we live in a
这是查尔斯·博诺（Charles Bono）的一句金玉良言，但这是真的。所以当我们从心理学的角度来谈论时，它在很大程度上是一种自主拥有的认同，它在任何形状或形式上都不一定与某人的生理学、生物学、解剖学、荷尔蒙、染色体等构成生物学性别的所有因素相对应。承认这一点很重要，因为某人走进房间，你看了一眼，把他们归类为某个特定的性别，但在你实际询问他们是否以此认同之前，你并不知道情况是否确实如此。这就是为什么有时我们很容易无意中说错话，因为我们会做出假设。首先要认识到，我们生活在一个
massively gendered society we have gendered everything from jobs to emotions to fashion all of it we have assumptions of we see this and we assume male we see that we assume female and that's the thing that we need to unpackage if we are going to make sure that at any moment when we meet somebody new or we encounter somebody new we are aware that they may not identify in the way we're going to assume that they will because we've been conditioned by the world we live in that's the first thing so anytime you might say oh yes and that you see that that lady down the end of the corridor that's the person immediately you do not know that person
性别色彩极其浓厚的社会中。我们把一切都赋予了性别，从工作、情绪到时尚，全都是这样。我们会有这样的假设：我们看到这个，就假设是男性；我们看到那个，就假设是女性。如果我们想确保在任何时候遇到新面孔或接触到新的人时，都意识到他们可能不会按照我们假设的那样去认同，我们就需要打破这种成见，因为我们已经被自己所处的世界所塑造了，这是第一点。所以任何时候你可能会说：“哦，是的，你看走廊尽头的那位女士……”那就是那个人——立刻，你并不知道那个人
may be wearing a dress but with that and if I was a lady would they identify as a lady even if they identified as a woman yeah it's all about recognizing the language we use can be very weighted and being conscious of as a starting point and and we can we can work around. So there's been a lot of conversations over recent years around pronouns and people sharing their pronouns and asking for pronouns, and that is a really significant thing. I have encountered people who have said, I see other people sharing their pronouns, but I'm a man, I'm clearly a man, people perceive me as a man, and therefore I don't need to share them because it's obvious.
可能穿着裙子，但带着这个……如果我是一位女士，她们会认同为女士吗？即使她们认同为女人？是的，这一切都是为了认识到我们使用的语言可能分量很重，并将其作为起点的意识，我们可以围绕这一点展开工作。近年来，关于代词、人们分享自己的代词以及询问代词，已经有了很多讨论，这是一件非常重要的事情。我曾遇到过这样的人，他们说：“我看到其他人分享他们的代词，但我是一个男人，我显然是一个男人，人们认为我是一个男人，因此我不需要分享，因为这很明显。”
And if we can reflect that back, we can say, well, if you are somebody who is regularly perceived by the world around you, by the people you encounter every day in the street, as the gender that you know yourself to be, then you have gender privilege. And what we are asking people to do by adding their pronouns to their email signatures or their their ID tags on their video calls and things like that is we are recognizing that not all people identify as the gender you may assume them to be when you see them on screen or encounter them in a in whatever setting you're in we don't know and by adding our own we help to normalize the process of including that as part of how we all generally identify first off it means
如果我们把这一点反思回去，可以说：如果你是一个经常被周围的世界、被你每天在街上遇到的人视为你内心深知的那种性别的人，那么你就拥有性别特权。我们要求人们在电子邮件签名、视频通话的身份标签等地方加上他们的代词，实际上是在承认：并非所有人所认同的性别，都与你在屏幕上看到他们或在任何你所处的环境中遇到他们时所假设的一致。我们并不知道。通过添加我们自己的代词，我们有助于将这个过程正常化，使其成为我们所有人普遍认同方式的一部分。首先，这意味着
that you're always going to be gendered correctly because your pronouns are right there but it also means that two things one you'll encounter people who say why do you put your pronouns on there you you you've got a beard and a deep voice you're clearly a man well actually not not all people who maybe have those features are men, and I'm making it clear that I am, and I'm also subtly telling the world, telling any person who is gender diverse that may encounter me, that I'm safe. I get it. I've thought about this stuff, and I recognize that as somebody who has gender privilege, I can start to normalize this process of asking for pronouns, making identifying one's own pronouns part of normal everyday culture. It takes the pressure off gender diverse people to always be the people who are saying excuse me can I just correct you there?
你的性别将永远被正确称呼，因为你的代词就在那里；但这也意味着两点：第一，你会遇到有人问：“你为什么要把代词写在上面？你长了胡子，声音低沉，你显然是个男人。”好吧，实际上，并非所有具备这些特征的人都是男人，而我正在明确表明我是，我也在向世界发出微妙的信号，向任何可能遇到我的、性别多元的人表明：我是安全的。我懂的。我考虑过这些事情，并且我认识到，作为拥有性别特权的人，我可以开始使询问代词、将认同自己的代词作为日常生活文化的一部分这一过程走向常规化。这减轻了性别多元人士的压力，让他们不必总是那些说“对不起，我能纠正你一下吗”的人。
Which every time you have to do that we've got that the negative impact that that has on somebody's mental well-being is significant especially when you're doing it 33 times a day so we start to help to take that pressure by being proactive in that kind of thing so that's that's the first point to acknowledge is we don't know i know that's specifically gender and we may want to talk about diversity and inclusion in a more broad way but that is one of the most significant questions i get asked what what's all this more broad way but that is one of the most significant questions I get asked what what's all this pronoun stuff about and that is what it's about that's really interesting and I know you know I think on LinkedIn because it offers you you know to choose your
每次你不得不这样做时，它对个人心理健康的负面影响都是巨大的，特别是当你一天要做 33 次的时候。因此，通过在这种事情上采取积极主动的态度，我们开始帮助减轻这种压力。所以这是需要承认的第一点：我们并不知道。我知道这具体是关于性别的，我们可能希望以更广泛的方式讨论多元化和包容性，但这是我被问得最多的最重要的问题之一：所有这些关于代词的事情到底是怎么回事？这就是它的意义所在。这真的很有趣，我知道——我想在领英（LinkedIn）上，因为它会让你选择你的
pronouns I have done that but like you said you know whilst I don't have a beard um I do have long hair and often wear dresses. And so I wouldn't necessarily have thought, for example, on this to put Dr. Marianne Trent, she, her. That would be my pronouns, wouldn't it? But I will do. I will work out how to change this on StreamYard and I will do because, yeah, I think you're right um just because I'm feeling like I know that I am a she and her um it does give gives the sign that I'm happy to have that conversation and see that as an important conversation to have so that's absolutely my first learning point from from talking with you so thank you for that Jay. No worries it's it's fascinating stuff it really is and just say i
代词，我已经那样做了。但就像你说的，虽然我没有胡子，嗯，我确实留着长发，而且经常穿裙子。因此，比方说，我可能不会自然而然地在这里写上“玛丽安·特伦特博士，她/她的”（Dr. Marianne Trent, she/her）。那会是我的代词，对吧？但我会去做的。我会研究如何在 StreamYard 上更改它，我会去做的，因为，是的，我觉得你是对的。嗯，仅仅因为我觉得自己知道我是“她/她的”，这确实表明我乐于进行这种对话，并认为这是一个重要的对话。所以这绝对是我从与你的交谈中获得的第一个学习点，谢谢你，G。不用谢，这真的很有趣，确实如此。而且我
know plenty of non-binary people and gender diverse people who to look at they have long hair they sometimes wear dresses it i don't know until you said that then i didn't know and then we've got a side issue here when it comes to titles you know you have a non-gender specific title which has pros and cons you know I would I have one mine is MX and that although it has been a legal title and and recognized for the last 20 years it isn't on every form that's also a very interesting conversation to have because I know you had quite a high profile battle with your mortgage provider when you moved recently didn't you could you tell us a bit about that because that was fascinating it was it was a little bit crazy but yes um my legal name is mux g just the letter g c just the letter c sabini roberts that is my
认识很多非二元性别者和性别多元者，从外表上看，他们留着长发，有时穿着裙子。在你刚才说之前我并不知道，然后这里还有一个附带的问题，当涉及到头衔时，你知道你有一个非性别特定头衔，它有利有弊。你知道，我有一个，我的是 Mx。虽然它一直是一个法律头衔，并且在过去 20 年里得到了承认，但它并不是在每张表格上都有。这也是一个非常有趣的对话，因为我知道当你最近搬家时，你曾与你的抵押贷款提供商进行过一场备受瞩目的斗争，不是吗？你能给我们讲讲那件事吗？因为那太迷人了。那确实有点疯狂，但是的，嗯，我的法定姓名是 Mx G，仅仅是字母 G，C，仅仅是字母 C，萨比尼·罗伯茨（Sabini Roberts），那是我的
complete legal name I changed it by people I have all the documentation my bank accounts are in that name am i my driving license is in that name that is my legal name and just as an aside anybody can change their name by deep hole to anything at any time and that is entirely legal so I have a legal name and it's what I go by at the start of this year my wife and I wanted to get a mortgage to buy the house that we now live in and the broker that we were working with came back and said right we've got the mortgage it's all agreed it's great and here it is and they had put Mrs. as my
完整的法定姓名。我通过更名契（deed poll）更改了它，我有所有的文件，我的银行账户都是这个名字，我的驾照也是这个名字，那是我的法定姓名。顺便说一句，任何人都可以随时通过更名契将名字改成任何名字，这完全是合法的。所以我有一个法定姓名，这也是我日常使用的名字。今年年初，我和妻子想申请抵押贷款来买下我们现在住的房子，我们合作的经纪人回来后说：“好了，我们拿到抵押贷款了，一切都谈妥了，太棒了，就是这样。”而他们在头衔一栏填的是“太太”（Mrs.）。
title. So of course we went back and said well actually that's that's not correct and can you change it please? This is the legal name and this was with one of the UK's biggest banking groups, in fact the biggest I think and we were basically they didn't have my title on their system. They couldn't figure out how to make it work. So well, we can't do that at which point we have a problem because we also have money laundering laws that state if you are taking out a financial agreement such as a mortgage
所以我们当然回信说：“嗯，实际上这不对，你能改一下吗？这是法定姓名。”而这是英国最大的银行集团之一，事实上我认为是最大的。基本上，他们的系统里没有我的头衔。他们想不出怎么让它运行。所以他们说：“嗯，我们做不到。”这就产生了一个问题，因为我们还有反洗钱法，其中规定，如果你在签订诸如抵押贷款之类的财务协议，
it has to be in your legal name otherwise you're breaking the law so we have two things going on here that is firstly we can't our systems the computer says no essentially our systems can't accommodate that because yes it's been around for 20 years but we haven't put it, our systems, the computer says no, essentially. Our systems can't accommodate that because, yes, it's been around for 20 years, but we haven't put it into our systems yet. And then you've got the book. We can't give you a different name. They did try to give me different names. They suggested Mrs. They then suggested V as my title.
它必须使用你的法定姓名，否则就是违法。所以这里有两件事正在发生：首先，我们不能……我们的系统——计算机基本上说“不”。我们的系统无法适应这一点，因为，是的，这个头衔已经存在 20 年了，但我们还没有把它放进——我们的系统——计算机基本上说“不”。我们的系统无法适应这一点，因为，是的，它已经存在 20 年了，但我们还没有把它放到我们的系统中。然后你就会遇到这种情况：我们不能给你一个不同的名字。他们确实试图给我不同的名字。他们建议用“太太”（Mrs.）。然后他们建议用 V 作为我的头衔。
V, G, C, Sabini Roberts. For some reason, they could make that work and they couldn't make Mooks work. And eventually, after weeks of wrangling, which, which of course we were in the process of trying to buy a house, it's not exactly a low key time. So it was quite a stressful situation, full stop. Eventually they did find a workaround with their systems. The media got hold of this because at one point i reached out and i said this is maddening and really frustrating how come you can't use my legal name i cannot be the first mux person who
V、G、C、萨比尼·罗伯茨。出于某种原因，他们能让这个行得通，却无法让 Mx 行得通。最后，经过几个星期的争执——当然，我们当时正处于买房的过程中，这绝不是一个低调的时期，所以这是一个相当有压力的全方位情况——他们终于在系统里找到了一个变通方法。媒体注意到了这件事，因为我曾一度联系他们说：“这太令人发狂了，也太令人沮丧了，为什么你们不能用我的法定姓名？我绝不可能是第一个尝试从这家大银行获得抵押贷款的 Mx 籍人士，这绝不可能。”然而，事实证明，我确实是第一个遇到这个问题的，然后没有退缩，并同意达成妥协。
has tried to get a mortgage with this massive bank it can't be the case however it turns out i was the first one to have that problem and then not back down and come and agree to a compromise and so we made it everywhere we were we were we were in the daily mail and on lad bible and all over the place talking about this the fact that this is such an issue and then ultimately celebrating the fact that they figured out how to make it happen and they are going to be changing their processes moving forward they now have a system by which people who have a title that isn't already on their system that they can actually use their legal name to get a legal mortgage it was it was huge um and it was just for me it was crazy that it in 2022 that it had to happen and it had to get as big as it did
于是我们登上了各处头条，我们上了《每日邮报》（Daily Mail），上了 Lad Bible 网站，到处都在谈论这件事。事实上，这已经成为了一个大问题，最后我们庆祝他们终于弄清楚了如何让它实现，并且他们将在未来改变他们的流程。他们现在有了一个系统，让那些拥有系统里原本没有的头衔的人，实际上可以使用他们的法定姓名来获得合法的抵押贷款。这真是太大了，对我和我来说，在 2022 年竟然必须发生这种事，而且事情闹得这么大，他们才真正想通如何去适配它，这太疯狂了。不过，真为你点赞，因为实际上正是因为你没有退缩：“这是正确的。这是对的。我相信这需要发生，而且它本来就应该可用。”而很多人会选择顺从，对吧？我本可以接受……
before they actually worked out how to make it fit. Well done to you, though, because actually it is that I'm not backing down. This is correct. This is right. And I believe this needs to happen and it should have been available. Whereas lots of people will just comply, won't they? I might have taken the um but like you said that's not my legal name I am not I am not the Marianne Trent um you know legally I'm doctor or missus um so those would be the options I would have gone and if doctor hadn't been available I would have gone with missus but actually I should have the choice to be able to say doctor if I want to um but not all systems are
但就像你说的，那不是我的法定姓名。我不是——我不是玛丽安·特伦特……你知道，从法律上讲我是博士或太太，所以这些是我本来会选的选项。如果“博士”不可用，我就会选“太太”。但实际上，如果我想说“博士”，我应该有选择说出来的权利，但并不是所有的系统都
geared up for that no and that's the same everywhere even within the NHS I am only registered with my legal name in some but not all aspects of of my health care simply because some systems can handle it now and some can't which is a challenge. And this is a challenge when we're looking at healthcare in a broader sense, because we have got different issues at play here. When we start looking at healthcare settings,
为此做好准备。没错，哪里都一样，甚至在 NHS（英国国民健保署）内部，我也仅在某些方面、而非全部的医疗保健记录中以法定姓名注册，仅仅因为有些系统现在能处理，而有些不能，这是一个挑战。当我们从更广泛的意义上看待医疗保健时，这也是一个挑战，因为这里有不同的问题在发挥作用。当我们开始关注医疗保健环境时，
I know we're talking specifically about psychology here, but it's the same if somebody is an inpatient for whatever reason, and they are in a ward with a group of people who are meant to be the same gender well if I was a trans man and I changed my I actually went through and changed my name on my medical records and changed my mark up my gender marker from a female to male then I would be invited for standard prostate screening. I would not be invited for cervical screening, for example. If I went into hospital and a trans man who goes through a full transition
我知道我们在这里专门讨论心理学，但如果有人由于某种原因住院，并且他们和一个理应属于同一性别的人群住在同一个病房里，情况也是一样的。如果我是一个跨性别男性，我改变了我的——我实际上经历了更名，并在医疗记录中将我的性别标记从女性改为了男性，那么我就会被邀请参加标准的的前列腺筛查。例如，我将不会被邀请参加宫颈筛查。如果我住进医院，一个经历过全面过渡的跨性别男性
is a man and will be perceived as a man by people in the street. He may have facial hair. He will have a deep voice. His body fat distribution in his body over a period of years of taking testosterone will you you will recognize him as a man but actually that man could still get cervical cancer for example and if they do and they're taken into hospital what would you put them in because if you put them in a gynecology ward and the five other people in that ward are women, looking at this bearded chap in the bed on the opposite side of the room, they're not going to feel comfortable. That man is not going to feel comfortable.
是一个男人，街上的人会把他视为男人。他可能长着胡须。他的声音很低沉。经过多年服用睾酮后，他身体内的体脂分布会发生变化，你会认出他是一个男人。但实际上，这个男人仍然可能患上宫颈筛查（宫颈癌），比如，如果他们患病并被送进医院，你会把他们安排到哪个病房？因为如果你把他们安排在妇科病房，而病房里的另外五个人是女性，看到房间对面病床上这个留着胡子的伙计，她们会感到不舒服。那个男人也不会感到舒服。
We actually have a challenge here to how we make trans-inclusive and gender diverse inclusive practices function i'm not i don't have an answer necessarily but there are very big questions on how we how we work this how do we find a way that meets everybody's needs absolutely and i think we're going to be really stirring the pot now rightly so in um in mental health services up and down the country as we all then go to our care notes software whatever software we're using and just looking at what pronouns are available and rattling some cages if the there's not more inclusive options available so yeah really important to to get our little renegade activists out into out into services yeah it's partly it's partly uh well pronouns and titles are different
我们在如何使跨性别包容和性别多元包容的实践发挥作用方面实际上面临着一个挑战。我并不一定有答案，但对于我们如何运作这一点，有着非常重大的疑问；我们如何找到一种满足每个人需求的方法？绝对是的，我认为我们现在将在全国上下的心理健康服务中真正激起浪花——这是理所应当的——当我们所有人随后去查看我们的护理记录软件或我们使用的任何软件，仅仅看看有哪些可用的代词，并在没有提供更多包容性选项时敲打敲打、提出质问。所以，是的，把我们的小叛逆激进分子带到服务中去，这真的非常重要。是的，这部分是——这部分是……嗯，代词和头衔是不同的。
i think that's an important thing to recognize is getting someone's name right matters that's an important part of treating them as a human being so having someone's name right is there but actually having a note on their records about pronouns is really useful because there's a lot of talking about people in the third person in a medical setting you will talk to other professionals who are working with that person and even if that person isn't the room it isn't in the room you should be using the pronouns that are right for that person is there a place on the records where we can say these are the pronouns that we use for this individual not to my knowledge not when I was in the NHS um but it might have changed I left in
我认为这是一个需要认识到的重要事情：把别人的名字叫对很重要，这是将他们视为人类的重要部分。所以把别人的名字叫对是基础，但实际上，在他们的记录上做关于代词的备注也非常有用，因为在医疗环境中有很多关于第三人称的讨论。你会与正在与该人合作的其他专业人士交谈，即使那个人不在房间里——即使不在房间里，你也应该使用适合该人的代词。记录中是否有这样一个地方，我们可以说“这些是我们针对这个个人使用的代词”？据我所知，没有。我在 NHS 工作时没有——但这可能已经改变了。我在 2021 年
April 2021 so it might have changed since then but to my knowledge there wasn't at that time but I would hope there will be if there isn't already. But yeah, I think if, you know, I spend a lot of time talking with aspiring psychologists, and the way that I would say this is I would say, when I am talking to a client, I will say, when I'm not with you, for example, when I'm talking in supervision, I will make sure that I always use your preferred pronoun of they and them, just so we're making those processes more transparent but also respectful yeah yeah very much yes and language goes further than that doesn't it yeah there will be people who have encountered the argument that's come out in the
2021年4月的情况，所以之后可能会有变化，但据我所知，当时是没有的，不过如果没有的话，我希望会有。但对，我想如果，你知道的，我花了很多时间与有志成为心理学家的人交流，我会这样表达：当我与来访者交谈时，我会说，当我不在你身边时，例如，当我在进行督导时，我一定会确保始终使用你偏好的代词“they”和“them”，这样不仅能让这些流程更加透明，也更加尊重对方。是的，确实如此，而且语言的作用不仅限于此，对吧？有些人可能会遇到这样一种观点，它出现在
last few years about expanding the language that we use in the services we offer the general public. As an example, we've got the breastfeeding and chestfeeding conversation and the fact that some trusts in the last five or so years have started to release information to their service users that talks about breastfeeding and chestfeeding or talks about the gestational parent as a way of making sure that people who are maybe non-binary or trans men who are going through pregnancy and having children
举个例子，我们有关于母乳喂养（breastfeeding）和胸乳喂养（chestfeeding）的讨论，事实上，在过去的五年左右里，一些信托机构（Trusts）开始向其服务使用者发布信息，谈论母乳喂养和胸乳喂养，或者将孕育父母（gestational parent）作为一种方式，以确保那些可能处于非二元性别或正在经历怀孕并生孩子的跨性别男性
are included in the services and are meant to feel safe and included and heard and respected within those services and we've had a lot of backlash from that as well. And that is quite a challenging one because that backlash and that argument is happening all the way up to the very top levels of decision making within all kinds of trusts and organisations and educational establishments. Those conversations are going on on and I think this is where it's it's it's appropriate to talk about this gender critical movement there is a section of the population section of all these organizations that are very against that evolution into more inclusive language based on the idea that we're actually in some way
被纳入这些服务中，并在这些服务中感到安全、被包容、被听到和被尊重。我们也因此遭到了很多强烈反对。这是一个相当具有挑战性的问题，因为这种强烈反对和争论一直蔓延到各种信托机构、组织和教育机构决策的最高层。这些对话正在进行中，我认为在这里讨论性别批判运动（gender critical movement）是恰当的。人口中的一部分人、所有这些组织中的一部分人，非常反对向更具包容性的语言演变，其理由是，我们实际上在某种程度上通过采取这些包容性的步骤而
excluding women or removing rights from women by taking these inclusive steps and I understand where those worries come from because people have said that I have encountered many people who say they've told us we can't use the word breastfeeding anymore we can't talk about ourselves as women we you know can't talk about pregnant women we have to talk about pregnant people I've heard all of those things what's really interesting is that they said they said that we can't which means I always get to go back and say who said that oh they did who say who's actually's they? Who's actually said that those arguments have been put forward by a very small but very committed anti-trans movement also sometimes
排除了女性或剥夺了女性的权利。我理解这些担忧来自何处，因为人们这样说过。我遇到过许多人，他们说：“他们告诉我们不能再使用‘母乳喂养’这个词了，我们不能谈论我们自己是女性，我们……你知道，不能谈论孕妇，我们必须谈论孕妇（pregnant people）。”我听过所有这些事情。非常有趣的是，他们说“他们说我们不能”，这意味着我总是可以回过头去问：“谁说的？”“他们说的。”“谁说的？到底谁是‘他们’？”那些争论是由一个极小但非常坚定的反跨性别运动（anti-trans movement）提出的，有时也被称为
referred to as the gender critical movement who ultimately are pitching two different marginalized groups against each other or women versus trans people whilst that infighting is going on use the right language don't use the right language someone up there is doing very well and the fact that they're getting away with not actually delivering brilliantly to both groups of people and the argument is focused elsewhere but it's about offering choice to the patient or the client isn't it so i identify as a woman and i think of these as my breasts and I use them to breastfeed my child and if someone who's been trying to support me in breastfeeding my children had been talking about it as chest feeding I would say well I identify as a woman
性别批判运动（gender critical movement）。他们最终将两个不同的边缘化群体对立起来——女性对阵跨性别者。当这种内讧发生时，使用正确的语言也好，不使用语言也罢，上面的某些人却过得很滋润，因为他们设法逃脱了未能真正向两个群体提供出色服务的责任，而争论的焦点则被转移到了别处。但这其实是关于为患者或客户提供选择，不是吗？所以，我认同自己是一个女人，我认为这些是我的乳房，我用它们来母乳喂养我的孩子。如果一直试图支持我母乳喂养孩子的人一直在把它称为“胸乳喂养”，我会说：“嗯，我认同自己是一个女人，
and these are my breasts so I'm happy to to call this breastfeeding but it's about knowing that that whatever I want to call them or the process is okay and encouraged by whoever I'm speaking with yeah and I think that is the point there is a fear that rights are being taken away language is being taken away identities are being taken away and that's not the case we are simply adding so you won't find literature that talks about chest feeding only you will talk find literature that talks about breastfeeding and chest feeding you won't find literature that talks about chest feeding only. You will find literature that talks about breastfeeding and chest feeding. You won't find literature that only talks about gestational parents. They will reference all aspects of being a gestational parent because everybody needs
这些是我的乳房，所以我很高兴称之为母乳喂养。”但这其实是关于知道，无论我想怎么称呼它们或者这个过程是什么，都是可以的，并且受到我正在交谈的任何人的鼓励。是的，我认为关键就在这里：人们担心权利被剥夺、语言被剥夺、身份被剥夺，但事实并非如此。我们只是在做加法。所以，你不会找到只谈论胸乳喂养的文献；你会找到同时谈论母乳喂养和胸乳喂养的文献。你不会找到只谈论胸乳喂养的文献。你会找到同时谈论母乳喂养和胸乳喂养的文献。你不会找到只谈论孕育父母的文献。它们会提及作为孕育父母的所有方面，因为每个人都需要
to be included in that rhetoric. It's like, the way I sort of reflect on it is imagine we have leaflets for our services and then we recognize that those leaflets are no use to our blind and visually impaired patients because they can't see them so we produce a braille version. We don't then stop producing the regular printed version and only make the braille one available. We simply add. We add so that we can include more people. And that's what we're doing by broadening the use of language when it comes to gender, is we are recognizing
被纳入这种修辞中。这就像——我反思它的方式是：想象一下，我们为服务准备了宣传册，然后我们意识到这些宣传册对我们的盲人和视障患者毫无用处，因为他们看不见，于是我们制作了盲文版本。我们并没有因此停止制作常规的印刷版，并只提供盲文版。我们只是做加法。我们进行添加，以便能够包容更多的人。这就是我们在谈到性别时拓宽语言使用时正在做的事情：我们认识到
that what we've got works brilliantly for the majority, let's keep that, but let's recognize it's not quite working well enough and add stuff in to fill the gap. That's what we're doing when we're saying, let's include different language in our conversations here. We're simply making, we're recognizing that it doesn't fit everybody and we want to make it fit everybody. People aren't going to access a service if they see the headline and it doesn't include them and that's where the problems lie because we know
我们所拥有的东西对大多数人来说效果极佳——让我们保留它——但也认识到它还不够完美，并添加一些东西来填补空白。这就是我们在说“让我们在这里的对话中加入不同的语言”时正在做的事情。我们只是在做到——我们认识到它并不适合所有人，而我们希望让它适合所有人。如果人们看到头条新闻却发现其中不包含自己，他们就不会去使用某项服务，而问题就出在这里。因为我们知道
that trans people have, are one of the groups that are least accessing services because they're afraid because they've had too many experiences where they have been excluded where they have been challenged in ways that are incredibly damaging to them I totally agree I totally agree and I know that you saw another niche in the market recently for thinking about diversity and inclusion and having very important conversations whilst also seeing yourself and other people being represented in just a standard thing like playing a card game. And that's another reason I wanted to talk to you, G. Could you tell us a little bit about your exciting new project, please? Absolutely. We had an accident where we created a new version of the Happy Families card game.
跨性别者是使用服务最少的群体之一，因为他们害怕，因为他们经历过太多次被排除在外、被以极具伤害性的方式质疑的经历。我完全同意，我完全同意。我知道你最近在多元化和包容性方面看到了另一个市场空缺，那就是在进行非常重要的对话的同时，也能让自己和其他人被代表，就像在一款标准的游戏（比如纸牌游戏）中一样。这也是我想和你聊聊的另一个原因，G。能跟我们讲讲你令人兴奋的新项目吗？绝对可以。我们发生了一个意外，我们创造了一个新版本的“幸福家庭”（Happy Families）纸牌游戏。
So I don't know if you've played the traditional Happy Families card game. I have, I have, as a child, not for a long time. Yeah, well, it's essentially like Go Fish. You have to collect all the members of a particular group and then once you've collected all of them, you've got those ones and the person who collects the most all the members of a particular group and then once you've collected all of them you've got those ones and the person who collects the most by the end of the game is the winner it's a fairly simple card game that's been played well since 1851 in fact
所以，我不知道你有没有玩过传统的“幸福家庭”纸牌游戏。我玩过，我玩过，作为小孩子的时候，已经很久没玩了。是的，好吧，它本质上就像“钓鱼”（Go Fish）。你必须收集特定群组的所有成员，一旦你收集了所有这些成员，你就拥有了这些牌，而到游戏结束时收集到最多特定群组所有成员的人就是赢家。这是一个相当简单的纸牌游戏，事实上自 1851 年以来就一直在玩了，当时它首次被创造出来。
when it was first created because i miss the baker family and stuff like that is that the baker family the butcher family so the original one had all these families that they're all white, they're all a husband, a wife, a son and a daughter, Mr, Mrs, Miss and Master and the surname is the father's profession. So it's based very much on these traditional notions of what families looked like back in the 1850s and we know that families don't look like that anymore. Occasionally they do, but families are way, way more diverse than that. And because of the business that I have, where I'm working with people with their branding and creating resources for them to market themselves and create products, one of the things I wanted to make available to people they were asking me can you help me make a deck of cards could be prompt cards or
因为我错过了面包师家庭之类的内容，那是面包师家庭吗？屠夫家庭？所以最初的版本有所有这些家庭：他们都是白人，都是一个丈夫、一个妻子、一个儿子和一个女儿，先生、太太、小姐和少爷，而姓氏则是父亲的职业。因此，它在很大程度上基于 1850 年代家庭样式的传统观念。而我们知道，现在的家庭已经不长那样了。偶尔会有，但家庭要多元得多。由于我经营的业务——我与人们合作进行品牌建设，并为他们创建用于营销和创造产品的资源——其中一件事就是我想让人们能够使用，他们一直在问我：“你能帮我做一副纸牌吗？可以是提示卡，或者
all kinds of different types of cars that people want to use within their businesses to help deliver what they do so I started looking into that and I found somebody brilliant LGBTQ printer up in Yorkshire and the queer own print company and we figured out a way to print cards. I thought, you know what, we'll do a test. And I had a look around and realised that there wasn't a version of Happy Families that was anything like representational of what modern families look like. And we ourselves are a blended family. We're a queer family.
各种不同类型的纸牌，人们希望在他们的业务中使用这些纸牌来帮助实现他们的工作。”所以我开始研究这个，我在约克郡找到了一家非常出色的 LGBTQ 印刷商——一家酷儿拥有的印刷公司，我们找到了一种印刷纸牌的方法。我想，你知道吗，我们来做个测试。我环顾四周，意识到市面上根本没有一个版本的“幸福家庭”能够代表现代家庭的样子。而我们自己就是一个重组家庭。我们是一个酷儿家庭。
We have non-binary family members. We're, you know, within our extended family, we're certainly not all white, we're a diverse bunch, as are probably most families. And so we created a new version of it that is full of different combinations of groups of people who call themselves families. We've got single parent families, we've got blended families, we've got family without children, we've got blended families, we've got family without children, we've got grandparents, we've got multi-generational stuff going on, we've got pets in there. We just mixed it up and
我们有非二元性别的家庭成员。我们，你知道的，在我们的大家庭里，我们当然不全是白人，我们是一群多元化的人，就像大多数家庭可能一样。所以我们创造了一个新版本，里面充满了各种不同组合的人群，他们称自己为家庭。我们有单亲家庭，我们有重组家庭，我们有丁克家庭（没有孩子的家庭），我们有重组家庭，我们有丁克家庭，我们有祖父母，我们有跨代同堂的情况，我们里面还有宠物。我们只是把它们混搭在一起，
we did this for fun. We've got a hundred boxes printed thinking over the next year we'll sell them to our friends and our friends' friends and that'll be lovely. And it's kind of blown up. so we're now on our third big print run and um we're starting out going to one of the big games expos next year and we have accidentally created an inclusive games production company in an entirely unexpected way which is lovely but it's um it wasn't something that we planned. Really lovely, but really important. And well, well done to you. There it is, happy families. But it's, I really, you know, I reached out to you, partly because of this, because when I was working in CAM services, which stands for Children Ad mental health services um we often you know play
我们这样做只是为了好玩。我们印了 100 盒，想着在接下来的一年里把它们卖给我们的朋友和朋友的朋友，那会很可爱。结果它有点火爆了。所以我们现在正在进行第三次大规模印刷，明年我们要去参加一个大型游戏展销会，我们以一种完全意想不到的方式意外地创建了一家包容性游戏制作公司，这很可爱，但这不是我们计划之中的。真的很可爱，但也非常重要。真为你点赞。就是这个，幸福家庭。但我真的——你知道的，我联系你，部分原因也是因为这个，因为当我还在 CAM 服务部门工作时——全称是儿童及青少年心理健康服务（Children and Adolescent Mental Health Services）——我们经常在与儿童和年轻人相互了解的同时，
games with um children and young people whilst we're kind of you know getting to know each other but also because sometimes some people find it really difficult to to talk one-on-one and so you're kind of busy yourself and be doing things but it's a really nice opportunity actually this card game to do something that feels inclusive and respectful but also helps many of the people who might be in our services to feel heard and understood and you know whether it's because of issues with gender and diversity or pronouns or you know ability or you know whether their family are you know their birth family it provokes lots of really important conversations that might well like i said be partly part of the reasons why we're actually
和他们玩游戏，而且这也是因为有时有些人会觉得进行一对一交谈真的很困难，所以你可以让自己忙于做一些事情。但实际上，这个纸牌游戏是一个非常好的机会，可以做一些让人感到包容和尊重的事情，同时也帮助许多可能在我们服务中的人感到被倾听和被理解。无论是由于性别与多元化的问题、代词的问题，还是能力的问题，或者他们的家庭是否是他们的原生家庭，它都会引发许多非常重要、可能正如我所说的那样正是我们首先在服务中见到他们的部分原因的对话。
seeing them in the service to begin with yeah very much so and i think this is one of the things or the biggest piece of feedback we've had from people has been we don't we don't define the family we simply say here's a group of people and for the purposes of this game they are a family. We don't know how many of those characters are trans or how many of them speak English or how many of them have hidden disabilities. We simply don't know and that's the point. We don't know if the family that has three adults in it is a blended family, are they a polyamorous family, are they a group of friends who are collectively raising a child? We don't know. We don't need to know. And that's the whole point
是的，确实如此。我认为这是人们给我们的最大反馈之一：我们不定义家庭。我们只是说：“这是一群人，为了这个游戏的目的，他们是一个家庭。”我们不知道这些角色中有多少人是跨原性别者，或者他们中有多少人说英语，或者他们中有多少人有隐性残疾。我们根本不知道，而这正是重点所在。我们不知道那个有三个成年人的家庭是一个重组家庭，还是一个多边恋家庭，还是一群共同抚养一个孩子的盆友？我们不知道。我们不需要知道。而这正是全部的意义所在。
is families can look like all kinds of things, they don't need to tick any particular boxes in order to be validly a family. And it comes down to representation. Particularly in young people, if you don't see yourself represented in the world around you, then you always will start to question, why? What's wrong with me? Why am I not there? Why am I so different? And little things like this help to alleviate that a bit and just show that all families go all families are valid and all families are okay and what we found has been brilliant is the way that people have jumped on this as a way to start having those conversations so
家庭的形式可以有千万种，它们不需要满足任何特定的条条框框就能成为名副其实的家庭。这归根结底关乎代表性。尤其是对年轻人来说，如果你在周围的世界里看不到自己的代表，你就会开始质问：为什么？我怎么了？为什么我不在那里？为什么我如此与众不同？像这样的小事有助于稍微缓解这种焦虑，并表明所有的家庭都是合理的，所有的家庭都没问题。我们发现非常棒的一点是，人们抓住这一点作为开启这些对话的一种方式，所以
hey let's play a game but you know by the end of the game you'll be having a conversation that's along the lines of so so do you think that person is is in a relationship with that person or do you think that person is in a relationship with that person? Or do you think these families might live next to each other? And how would that work? And you get to start those easy conversations, open conversations, without putting anyone on the spot. Important conversations to have.
嘿，我们来玩个游戏吧。你知道的，到游戏结束时，你们会开始进行这样的对话：“你觉得那个人和那个人在恋爱吗？”或者“你觉得那个人和那个人在谈恋爱吗？”或者“你觉得这些家庭会住在隔壁吗？那会是怎么样的？”你可以借此轻松地开启这些对话，在不让任何人感到尴尬的情况下进行开放式的对话。这些都是很重要的对话。
Show us the pack again up to the camera so people know what they're looking for, G. It's that. At the moment, the happy uh it's the business we've set up is the rainbow family circus so it's rainbowfamilycircus.co.uk and you'll find all the information about the game and be able to buy it on there but we've got you know we've got a single dad family or a masculine presenting person and we have mixed race families we've got um a two dad family we've got two mom family we've got an adult only family or maybe one of them's a teenager or we don't know maybe they're siblings we don't know we don't need to know yeah they do have a very cool power of them
把这个包装盒再次拿给镜头看看，好让大家知道他们在找什么，G。就是这个。目前，这个快乐的……呃，我们成立的业务是彩虹家庭马戏团，网址是rainbowfamilycircus.co.uk，你可以在上面找到关于这个游戏的所有信息并购买。我们有单亲爸爸家庭，或者具有男性特质的人，我们有混血家庭，我们有双爸爸家庭，我们有双妈妈家庭，我们有只有成年人的家庭，或者其中可能有一个是青少年，我们也不知道，也许他们是兄弟姐妹，我们不知道，我们不需要知道。是的，他们确实有一种非常酷的力量
it's stay curious isn't it and you know, give people permission to be who they are and help facilitate conversations, you know, in an open, non-judgmental space. So thank you so much for your time. I feel like I could have spoken to you all day about so many different topics. But, yeah, I will make sure that I put details about you and your social handles in the show notes. And of course, tag you in this podcast as well. And the wonderful the wonderful Happy Families game.
这就是保持好奇心，对吧？你知道的，允许人们做自己，并帮助在一个开放、不带批判色彩的空间里促进对话。非常感谢你抽出时间。我觉得我可以和你聊上一整天，聊那么多不同的话题。但是，是的，我一定会把关于你和你的社交账号的详细信息放在节目简介里，当然，也会在这个播客中@你，还有那个美妙的、美妙的“快乐家庭”游戏。
So thank you so much for your time and for so richly and generously spreading your knowledge with with our audience. You're very welcome. Can I leave you with one thing? Please do. One of the things you said right at the start of this conversation was recognising that sometimes people have a fear of getting things wrong. And I just want to tell them that that's okay. You will get things wrong. I get things wrong. We all get things wrong. If you inadvertently misgender somebody or use the incorrect name or title there's a really easy answer you just say oh I'm sorry I meant the right one and you move on that's the really key thing acknowledge it and move on that's all you
所以非常感谢你抽出时间，如此慷慨、丰富地与我们的听众分享你的知识。不客气。我能留给你们一件事吗？请讲。你在这次对话刚开始时说的一件事是，认识到有时人们害怕犯错。我只想告诉他们，没关系的。你会犯错的。我会犯错的。我们都会犯错。如果你无意中使用了错误的性别代词，或者使用了错误的姓名或称呼，有一个非常简单的解决方法：你只要说“哦，对不起，我指的是正确的那个”，然后继续往下聊。这才是最关键的一点——承认它并继续前进，这就是你
need to do you will get it wrong I misgender myself sometimes it's okay to get it wrong as long as you put it right. Yeah, absolutely. And I think there's been a very high profile case in the palace recently of someone not backing down and apologising and, you know, actually really offending somebody about their about their heritage. And I think there can be a lot to be said, but just saying, you know, I'm sorry, I misunderstood. I got it all wrong and I'm really sorry. But, yeah, this is just, you know, give people mission to be human and to be who they are and know that we can't get everything right all the time. But if we do it with the best of intentions, hopefully, and apologize when we do get it wrong, we'll do more good than harm. We will, indeed. Thank you so much for your time gee thank you it's been a real pleasure wow wasn't that amazing gee is incredible um and i certainly learned a lot there so will you be changing um your socials to say what your preferred gender pronouns are.
需要做的全部。你会犯错的，有时我也会把自己的性别代词用错。只要你纠正过来，犯错是没有关系的。是的，绝对是这样。我认为王室最近有一个备受瞩目的案例，有人不肯认错和道歉，实际上真的因为他们的背景而深深冒犯了某人。我认为这很有说明意义，只需说：“听着，对不起，我误解了。我全弄错了，我真的很抱歉。”但是，是的，这只是，你知道的，给予人们犯错和做自己的权利，并知道我们不可能总是把所有事情都做对。但如果我们抱着最好的意图去做，希望如此，并在犯错时道歉，我们就会利大于弊。确实如此。非常感谢你抽出时间，G，谢谢你，这真是一次愉快的交流。哇，那不是太棒了吗？G太不可思议了，呃，我确实在那里学到了很多。那么，你会不会更改你的社交媒体，标明你倾向的性别代词呢？
Is that something you could consider doing? I absolutely am going to be doing that in future. So I will be changing my overlay to tweak it to say she and her. So, yeah, thank you for that important conversation, G. Hope you found that useful. Please do come along and discuss it on the Aspiring Psychologist Community free Facebook page. As promised, there is an exclusive competition. I have bought two copies of the Happy Families Progress Edition. That's them shaking card games that we discussed in the episode
这是你可以考虑做的事情吗？我绝对会在未来这样做。所以我将更改我的覆盖层，将其调整为“she”和“her”。所以，是的，谢谢你带来的重要对话，G。希望你觉得这很有用。请一定要来“有抱负的心理学家社区”免费Facebook主页上参与讨论。正如承诺的那样，有一个独家比赛。我买了两份“快乐家庭进阶版”。就是我们在节目中讨论的那套摇晃纸牌游戏
i'm going to give both of those away one over on linkedin and one over on instagram so do come and connect with me on both of those platforms i am dr marian Marianne Trent in both places. And the competition will run until midnight on Monday, the 2nd of January 2023. So yeah, come along, take part. I don't quite know what the details of the competition are going to be yet, but I will by the time you listen to this. So you've got a week, but don't wait. Do it today because I will post a copy. If you're the winner on Instagram or you're the winner on LinkedIn, I'll post those to you in the UK. So, yeah, G kindly said that she was happy for me to to run the competition. So I bought those. So I bought those along with my own version. So I do actually have three.
我要把这两套都送出去，一套在领英（LinkedIn）上，一套在Instagram上。所以欢迎大家在两个平台上与我联系，我在这两个地方都是玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）。比赛将持续到2023年1月2日星期一午夜。所以，是的，快来参加吧。我还不知道比赛的具体细节会是什么，但在你听到这个的时候我就会知道了。所以你有一周时间，但不要等待。今天就做吧，因为我会寄出一套。如果你是Instagram上的赢家或者领英上的赢家，我会把它们寄到英国的你手上。所以，是的，G好心地表示她很高兴让我来举办这个比赛。所以我买下了这些。所以我和我自己的版本一起买的。所以我其实有三个。
I'm going to keep one and play those with my children but yeah if you would like to have a copy for your children and families service or for your own private practice working with children and young people or just to play with your family then please do swing over to LinkedIn or Instagram or both. You can enter on both platforms. Yeah, and I will be delighted to post those to you if you are the winner. We'll get my lucky prize wheel wheeling around again. So yeah, thank you so much for listening. Hope you found it useful. And yeah, good luck if you do decide to enter. Thanks for listening and I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode that lands with you from 6am on Monday. Thanks for being part of my world and On the way to getting qualified
我要留一个，和我的孩子们一起玩。但是，是的，如果你想为你的儿童和家庭服务机构、你为儿童和青少年服务的私人诊所拥有一套，或者只是为了和你的家人一起玩，那么请一定要去领英或Instagram或两者都看看。你可以在这两个平台上参与。是的，如果你是赢家，我将很高兴把它们寄给你。我会再次转动我的幸运奖盘。所以，是的，非常感谢大家的收听。希望你觉得它有用。如果你决定参赛，祝你好运。感谢收听，我期待在周一早上6点发布的下一集节目中与大家相聚。感谢你成为我世界的一部分，以及在获得资格的道路上
So many tips and lessons to learn from So many things that you can try The Aspiring Psychologist Collective Inspiring Psychologist Collective If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
有这么多的技巧和经验需要学习 有这么多你可以尝试的事情 “有抱负的心理学家集体” “有抱负的心理学家集体” 如果你正在寻找成为一名心理学家 那么就让这成为你的指南 有这个播客在你身边 你将在获得资格的道路上前进 这是“有抱负的心理学家”播客
With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay.
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫亚娜（Jana），是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现其中关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有多少条不同的途径可以到达那里，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径可以成为其中的一员，这让我充满了信心，不，我并没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可留下评论。